et on va parler du groupe armé et un
islam et qui semble avoir des problèmes
de revenus pour financer son expansion
travailler que ce soit en fait les
frappes aériennes de la coalition
internationale qui commence à faire mal
l'état islamique
il semble que oui en fait depuis des
mois maintenant les américains en tête
pilonnent 107 les positions en irak et
en syrie et du groupe ita armes
islamique il reste que pour l'instant
combien d'argent parvient-il à récolter
chaque mois c'est environ 80 millions de
dollars
par quels moyens en fait principalement
en imposant des taxes et des impôts aux
populations sur lesquelles il règne que
ce soit en syrie ou en irak mais
également aussi beaucoup d'argent
provient de la vente du trafic du
pétrole et du gaz dont les champs
pétrolifères et gaziers sur lequel
évidemment ils ont mis la main en
essayant de conquérir le territoire
maintenant il ya des problèmes de budget
c'est un peu comme une entreprise il
faut essayer d'équilibrer son budget on
a des dépenses et on a des revenus alors
il se rend bien compte qu'on ne gère pas
une entreprise comme on gère un
territoire et une population évidemment
donc il ya plusieurs problèmes qui vient
de se greffer là-dessus
et en plus vous l'avez dit perte de
revenus énormes à cause des
bombardements aient eu plus de 8300
raids aériens les américains 1 80% à peu
près ensuite les russes se sont joints
et les français aussi depuis les
attentats en plus voilà est donc
difficile pour eux de continuer à
acheminer le pétrole et surtout ils ne
peuvent pas compter sur des dons par
exemple comme peut le faire al qaïda
alors qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
face à ce défi pour eux alors je veux un
peu faire le gérald fillion en fait de
l'état islamique c'est à dire que il
faut équilibrer le budget donc il faut
réduire les dépenses et il faut
augmenter les revenus ce qu'on fait dans
ce cas ci c'est qu'on va baisser les
salaires des combattants un peu comme si
on a baissé la solde des militaires ici
et puis on va augmenter le coût des
services pour la population que ce soit
pour les systèmes de téléphonie ou
encore de l'électricité alors je vous
rappelle quand même que les principales
sources de financement pour l'état
islamique qui vient bien sûr mon
production et trafic de pétrole et de
gaz la taxation des activités
commerciales
on met la main aussi sur les revenus des
entreprises publiques et on essaie de
diversifier les sources de revenus donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait à ce moment là pour
le groupe armé état islamique
on s'en va dans la confiscation des
terres et des propriétés dans le trafic
de drogue et d'antiquités on en a
souvent déjà parlé céline et puis
surtout des activités criminelles comme
par exemple
l'enlèvement les demandes de rançon et
maintenant on songe même du côté du
groupe armé et à l'islam et qui a imposé
une taxe supplémentaire pour ceux qui
songerait à quitter la syrie
eh bien merci au programme dont je vous
en prie